vi faccio vedere una cosa oggi di solito
per preparare un video tutto quello di
cui parlo tutta la struttura anche solo
parole chiave
le scrivo in questo enorme blocco note
ne ho cambiati tanti ma in questo in
particolare ci sono anni anni anni di
video ci sono liste ci sono idee ci sono
proprio video scritti parola per parola
virgola per virgola perché le idee
preferisco scriverle a mano o per un
semplice motivo di velocità mi trovo
molto più comodo a sul pullman con un
pezzettino di carta a scrivere
velocemente un po come eminem in eight
mile
mi sono appena paragonato dei mille non
era quella l'intenzione però è perché mi
mi trovò proprio molto meglio farlo
tutto questo per dirvi che questi sono i
miei appunti su adam kadmon ci sono
talmente tanti piccoli particolari che
non ho idea di come iniziale non avevo
idea di come buttare giù tutte le idee
tutte le informazioni che ho trovato è
quindi oggi si improvvisa completamente
[Musica]
per le tre o quattro persone che non
sappiano chi sia
adam kadmon e questo personaggio weekend
dice immaginario che è nato nel 2005 in
un blog
poi è stato acchiappato dallo zoo di 105
qualche anno dopo e nel 2010 è approdato
per essere poi conosciuto da tutta
italia nella trasmissione
incredibilmente realistica e
assolutamente non trash mistero è
diventato famoso non solo per tener
nascosta la sua identità dietro ad una
mascherina ma soprattutto per le sue
incredibili teorie complotti sulla su
tutto il mondo praticamente salite tutti
a bordo si salva teorie del complotto
esoterismo spionaggio di massa queste
parole non sono soltanto le protagoniste
dei libri di tom clancy ma sono anche il
piatto principale degli argomenti di
adam entry lo posso giurare quando lui
faceva mistero era ovunque tutti ne
parlavano tutti lo imitavano ma
soprattutto tutti non prendevano per il
culo
la percezione è una cosa molto
contestuale no è in base a l'ambiente in
cui vivi cambia tantissimo la percezione
di determinate cose
ecco quella di adam kadmon era
costantemente al cento per cento
negativa sto pone l'uomo nessuno lo
prendeva sul serio
mai insomma che non è che la gente
avesse proprio tantissimo rispetto di
questo però siamo qui per rispondere ad
una domanda molto specifica che fine ha
fatto dopo che mistero è finito
partiamo dalle origini della sua
popolarità mistero vista e lo era questa
trasmissione televisiva che all'inizio è
nata semplicemente per raccontare tutto
quello che di occulto e di alieno
accadeva nel mondo che ha un dono
particolare riesce a vedere quello che
solo alcune persone dicono di poter
percepire ovvero gli angeli quindi era
alla stregua di qualsiasi libro
documentario o addirittura canale di
youtube che trattava gli stessi
argomenti e man mano che passano gli
anni la trasmissione diventa sempre meno
informativa ed interessante è sempre più
immondizia
io lo so cosa volete vedere io lo so che
voi volete che io vi risvegli un ricordo
prego una bambina gli tira un sasso
improvvisamente la figura si alzano è un
uomo armato di asciano sicuramente
quella del cavallo di battaglia di
mistero ma c'era un altro servizio che
mi è sempre sembrato anche più trash di
quello ma a cui nessuno ha dato tanto
peso che è quello il servizio di quella
signora che ha partorito un se tu alieno
e loro l'hanno fatto vedere con tanto di
testimonianze fotografie ei video o mate
portavano via fisicamente fisicamente un
cono di luce
purtroppo per noi interessati al mondo
del paranormale quella storia era una
ciofeca però insomma quante risate ci
siamo fatti di mistero purtroppo su web
di mare molto poco perché a un certo
punto mediaset ha fatto tabula rasa di
tutti i contenuti ricaricati dalle
persone ma insomma se tu vai su ebay il
nostro migliore amico di sempre si trova
qualcosina le riviste sono allo stesso
livello della trasmissione ovviamente
spiriti in casa dice la copertina ma io
quello che leggo e gli enigmi di
alessandro magno i men in black sono tra
noi gli snuff movies verità o leggenda
santo cielo scary christmas quando i
giocattoli incontrando il paranormale
il mio preferito in assoluto robbie
williams occulto ma povero e queste sono
le liste del 2015
mi sono chiesto a novembre 2020 di cosa
parleranno a volte mi faccio delle
domande veramente veramente stupido e sa
come e quando morirà la terra o
tal'altro di leggere queste cose
mi porta indietro a destra nel periodo
in cui guardavo tantissima televisione è
uno dei miei programmi preferiti real tv
è stato disintegrato da una conduzione
di cristina chiabotto completamente nuda
coperta nei punti giusti da degli
sprechi e con lei che diceva frasi da
baci perugina ve lo state ricordando
forse era meglio di no
[Musica]
siccome non mi sono fatto nessuna
scaletta andiamo di portatile dopo per
la marca perché non è sponsorizzato va
beh non so perché ogni volta che io
cerco informazioni su un vip mezzo
sparito su una meteora trovo sempre un
suo sito che mi fa morir dal ridere
il sito di adam 777 babylon 777 punto
blogspot.com
volete fare un tuffo negli anni 90 anche
se il sito non è degli anni 90
[Musica]
mi fanno male gli occhi perché non ho
idea di dove guardare dove mettere il
focus
questo è il famoso blog di a lancome
anche lui aggiornato costantemente ci
saranno 4.000 e 5.000 parole scritte con
37 link e l'effetto anni 90 non è
soltanto la miriade di pop up che ti
appaiono in faccia quando lo aprì ma
anche quello splendido sfondo del mare
si può scoprire che ad hama due pagine
facebook quella d'autore di libri e
quella di poesie brevi tra l'altro a
casa io uno dei suoi libri condividi
subdolamente sottilmente intitolato
complotti e un'altra di tante piccole
cose che mi ha fatto sempre sorridere di
agam sono i titoli degli altri sui libri
ma amundi apocalypsis 616 babylon 777
lux tenebre e il nominato di questi non
sono libri questa la tracklist di un
album dei children of bodom è molto
attivo anche sulla sua pagina instagram
ma lui sta continuando sta continuando a
lavorare
semplicemente nella sfera web se si
scende un pochino sul sito si trovano
gli album musicali se il signor cadmo
neanche un cantante
chi non sapeva questa informazione ora
ce l'ha
nell'anticamera del proprio cervello
avete questa informazione che vi
rimbalzano adam kadmon ha fatto degli
album musicali però non riesce a uscire
questa informazione
da lì sapete perché perché vi state
immaginando quali tipi di album quale
tipo di musica canti un uomo che ha
passato la vita ad avvertirci con dei
complotti internazionali
uguale il genere musicale canta adam
kadmon
[Musica]
c'è
ci avete preso in pieno e proprio musica
leggera italiana anni 70
tutto mi sarei immaginato tranne di
fettine lucio battisti aver ascoltato la
combattiva nuvole ad est il gabbiano di
novembre un vuoto in mezzo che sa di
eterno come difficile parentesi piangere
ma fuori sorridere oppure dolce bolla di
sapone parentesi come difficile parte 2
[Musica]
io lo sapevo che sarebbe stato quello
che mi avrebbe fatto più ridere questo
anche senza forma santo cielo lo compro
comunque passiamo al prossimo argomento
che molto probabilmente ancora meglio se
non avete voglia di leggere perché siamo
nel 2021
potete sempre andare sul suo canale di
youtube ancora attivissimo i titoli non
aiutano con l'ansia per esempio la nuova
variante del virus
cosa sta davvero accadendo nel mal
amundi messaggio importante ai potenti
della terra è importantissimo che
ricevano subito dal governo stesso
tutto ciò che gli occorre ma in italiano
il problema di diventare adulti con
internet è che quando poi tu fai un
video pensi che determinate cose siano
decenti ve lo posso dire a voi ea tutti
i genitori in ascolto no se pensate di
mettere qualche ghiffa animata nel
vostro video
fermatevi subito io non me li ricordavo
così tanto incasinati scusate il termine
tecnico
guardate che roba poi c'è sempre il suo
logo adam kadmon con la firma ad ankara
mons questo canale a dei video che
definirei inspiegabili non per motivi
paranormali
ma che non riescono a risponde alla
domanda delle tre che sono stati
caricati cui adam kadmon trademark
esiste parola del regista luigi parisi
luigi parisi regista italiano dell'onore
e rispetto il mercato e la vergogna
sangue caldo a un certo punto decide di
fare un video dedica ad adam kadmon
dicendo che noi esiste esiste un video
di due minuti dove dice alan carbone
esiste e ciao
e caricata a salve sono luigi parisi e
sono un regista perché è una persona e
non un personaggio pezzo lo faccio
anch'io
a un certo punto senza preavviso
caricare un video di due minuti di
matteo garrone che dice ciao sono matteo
garrone
forse vi ricorderete diretto toc man e
volevo dirvi che karim è veramente
piacevole alla vista
arrivai io sono felicissimo di aver
scoperto queste cose di adam perché ha
reso un personaggio che io e purtroppo
anche altri miei coetanei molto diverso
da una persona normale l'abbiamo sempre
visto come questa entità che sfornava
complotti su complotti su complotti ma
scoprire queste cose qui l'ho preso una
persona una persona umana e non so
perché questa cosa mi rende felice
perché è una cosa che si potrebbe
rapportare a qualsiasi altra persona
quando tu vedi un film un libro una
canzone un contenuto su internet che ti
fa veramente cagare inizi ad odiare il
suo creatore
se riesce a un certo punto a distaccare
il contenuto della persona riesce a
scoprire altri lati che magari ti
potrebbero piacere di più del contenuto
che crea io ti voglio un gran bene adam
ti ringrazio per tutte le le risate
involontarie che mi ha fatto fare nel
corso degli anni e spero che tu riesca a
proseguire nel tuo mistico e paranormale
viaggio
un abbraccio
adam kadmon
[Musica]